[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
kultur cool dass ich das video machen
darf es handelt sich eigentlich um
meinen hauptraum im ganzen haus ich
hatte schon ein paar videos gesehen von
sally und zwar gibt es ja viele die
wohnung meiner eltern unser wohnzimmer
und schlafzimmer und der heute geht es
ums arbeitszimmer und gerade im
arbeitszimmer habe ich die entscheidung
treffen dürfen was da drin sein wird es
merkt euch immer wenn ihr mal unsere
räume anschaut alle dunklen räume die
dürftig gestalten und gibt es leider nur
einem haus naja e2 zum haus und die
dürftig entscheiden besser als helle
entschieden
deswegen bin ich auch richtig froh
darüber dass ich euch das jetzt zeigen
da was wir gemacht haben und hier drin
wie gesagt werden die wichtigsten
entscheidungen getroffen von celles welt
von unserem team von unseren freunden
und deswegen komisch mal rein
er ist schon kommt der 1 es hätten sich
er ist schauen wir müssen reden
ich habe jetzt nach jahrelanger
zusammenarbeit gut oder nicht gut
festgestellt auch die kollegen sie
können gar nichts gar nichts
ich war immer der meinung ich habe mal
morgens der erste und abends der letzte
der gegangen ist ja dachte ich habe
immer mal ihre meinung interessiert
niemanden
er ist ja wie sind sie brot kann
schimmel wenn man das kind das war's
festige bikinis welt sie sind entlassen
auf wiedersehen
wir sprechen uns noch ich komme wieder
bitte
ja ich habe noch glück gehabt der hat
mich doch nicht gefeuert und ich darf
trotzdem da bleiben und er hat die macht
nicht an sich gerissen
und wie gesagt diese raum hier ist das
arbeitszimmer von mir von sally
eigentlich von jedem hier ist jeder drin
auch die kinder sind oftmals hier drin
jetzt sehr aufgeräumt und ich muss ja
ganz ganz ehrlich sagen es ist
aufgeräumt ich habe davor aufgeräumt
sind nicht immer so schön aus muss ich
ehrlich sagen und ich wünsche euch mal
gerne ein bisschen an dem raum bisschen
erklären warum wir es gemacht haben der
raum hatten auch ein paar coole hacks
drin
die vielleicht daheim auch mal selber
nach machen könnt und ich möchte ein
wieder inspirieren was man so alles
machen kann
wir haben ein paar fehlplanungen gehabt
in diesem ganzen raum und die würde ich
auch gern mal erzählen und wie wir sie
gelöst haben richtig wichtig war uns im
ganzen haus gesundes wohnklima zu haben
das heißt wir haben materialien
natürliche materialien verwendet ich
wollte keine ausdünstungen haben wir
haben extrem auf qualität geachtet und
bei der ganzen wandgestaltung ein thema
wandgestaltung wollte ich einfach
natürlich dinge drin haben und wie bei
den video wandgestaltung haben wir hier
so benutzt um pompeji ist ein
mineralstoff das ist sozusagen das was
die vulkanasche ist 100 prozent
natürlich und das habe ich mit robert um
kumpel von mir selber aufgetragen und es
ging auch relativ flott muss ich sagen
ist ok und bin ich ganz ganz ehrlich bin
auch wenn ihr vielleicht keine große
ahnung habt die wand hier komplett das
ganze zimmer wenn du ein bisschen flott
bis schaffst es wirklich in zwei bis
drei stunden das den komplett fertig zu
bekommen ist richtig die coole
geschichte und da haben wir so einen
grauton genommen ich finde immer wenn
etwas dunkler ist dann wird es ein
bisschen edler und es kommt auch die
kontraste besser rauschenden sachen an
die wand hengst und es ist richtig schön
glatt und es ist 100 prozent natürlich
und das war mir das wichtige ist ok
eine hammer empfehlung wenn ihr das
vielleicht nicht habt oder wenn es zu
teuer ist was es auch gibt inzwischen
habe ich auch schon gesehen eine coole
lösung ist von imi beton beton hat es
auch die da kannst du ganze panels
nehmen und die wand geboren und kleben
ist auch eine richtig coole variante und
informiert euch mal übers tor pompei
oder in beton
da gibt es richtig coole wandtafeln auch
wie gesagt ich wollte um mexiko haben
richtig genial richtig edel sieht auch
toll aus und wie wir das gemacht haben
sehen wir jetzt hier ganz kurz
[Musik]
drüben haben wir diese glatte ist ok und
sie ist auch kalt wirklich dies auch
kalt und ein bisschen wärme auch im büro
rein zu bekommen ich finde immer so büro
ist immer so kalt und es ist kann auch
gemütlich sein und deswegen haben auf
der anderen seite holz genommen und das
haben wir ganz ganz coole konstellation
war es oftmals wenn ihr selber baut
werde selber merken es bleiben euch mal
baustoffe übrig jetzt hast du zb ein
paket bestellt man das gemerkt hey wir
sind noch zehn quadratmeter übrig
geblieben da haben wir wirklich diesem
parkett genommen und zwar ist der
gleiche boden wie mama trüben hat das
ist ein kers parkett der kommt aus
schweden ist richtig ein massiver packe
100 prozent natürlich und da haben wir
einfach mit dem alex zusammen diesen
kers parkett an die wand geklebt und ist
auch richtig cool aus also da gehabt so
eine richtig schöne wärme drinnen und
absolut kontrast zu anderen
gegenüberliegenden wand und einfach ich
wollte wärme drinnen haben deswegen war
das so wichtig und wie ich das gemacht
habe
neben alex zusammen das schaut ihr euch
jetzt mal an dem robert zusammen haben
wir gestern denn den stuck gemacht auf
allen seiten
und jetzt ist folgendes passiert ich
wollte ja eigentlich diese
holzvertäfelung und das ist ein echtes
holz und das probleme einfach ich habe
das im angebot gekauft weil ich gedacht
habe ich schieß wieder ein schnäppchen
und habe 13 quadratmetern geholt und
jetzt brauche ich normalerweise für die
ganze wand wright genau 13 quadratmeter
jetzt hast natürlich auch verschnitt
drin jetzt habe ich angst es nicht mehr
reicht und ich habe jetzt im alex
entschieden dass wir nicht mehr diese
verteilung an die wand machen weil ich
kriege jetzt auch mehr bestellt weil es
waren restposten
jetzt machen wir was ich schon etwas
gemacht habe und zwar machen wir diesen
kers parkett an die wand dieser kers
parkett da kommt doch schweden ist es
also richtiges team voll holz ist es
richtig genial auch richtig dick bin ja
dass hier sehen könnt und wir machen
jetzt diese fertigung an die band
anstatt diese holzvertäfelung weil
damals noch genug da und da alex hat
eigentlich schon mal gemacht und zwar da
hat hier nur leider konzept
er hat hier schon die leitung hier an
den körper an gemacht und jetzt gehen
wir wirklich hin im alex und werden hier
dieses holz an die wand kleben richtig
alex genau senkrecht an die wand machen
und es ist immer cool also auch wenn
beim haus etwas macht möchte wirklich
haben wir ein bisschen was drauf habe
ich habe ein bisschen was drauf aber
natürlich der alex der kennt sich
richtig raus der roberto ist ein
fliesenleger macht wandgestaltungen da
alex kennt sich mit holz alles was mit
holz zu tun hat kennt sich da alex aus
und man seine freunde hat die einem
helfen kann dadurch viel geld sparen und
das macht ihm richtig spaß und ich bin
ja eigentlich zu hilfe oder ein bisschen
was kann ich auch oder bisher ist kann
ich auch okay
und wie gesagt jetzt haben zwei tage
zeit jetzt drückt halt ein bisschen der
schule könne nicht mehr lange warten
wir haben jetzt zwei tage zeigt diese
wand zu machen dass kriege normalerweise
hin schaffe nur weil auch in zwei tagen
kommen nämlich die ersten möbel schon
und deswegen möchte man schon mit der
raumgestaltung schon hier fertig sein
okay also dann haltet uns nicht länger
auf schau denn so ein bisschen zu wie
wir das machen
eine ganz ganz coole idee macht es bitte
nicht mit laminat machten es mit dem
rolls mit dem parkett ist es richtig
cool was natürlich auch der vorteil ist
bei holz holz ist ein sehr dankbare
rohstoff sage ich ja auch immer wieder
und wir haben jetzt zum beispiel
steckdosen mittag einen stromschlag kein
strom mehr drauf und des kunden die auf
die die aussparung für steckdosen ganz
einfach mit einer krone kann man dir ein
segen rein worden ist ganz ganz einfach
tom kann man gefallen tun kannst du mal
den tipp da hinten filmen dass er
aufhören soll dauern das fenster rein zu
gucken den genannten brett vorm kopf
willst du das wissen der mysteriösen der
nachbar auf jeden fall
wir fangen jetzt an und jetzt schaut uns
zu und wir lassen ist ein bisschen
lassen gopro laufen dass wir keine zeit
verlieren okay alex mama
[Musik]
also ich habe jetzt angefangen bis zur
hälfte und andres grad um so und dann
sieht nach den ausrüster nicht cooler
typ von alex übrigens auf die idee wäre
ich selber nicht gekommen
sie können gar nichts gar nichts dann
haben wir hier ein rebell of style das
ist ein klebemittel es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten man könnte zum beispiel
auch die bretter jetzt an nagel
sozusagen oder angeboren
wir haben hier in dem tonband aber wir
nehmen hier ein klebemittel das heißt
wir werden einfach großflächig den klebe
merkel hier auf der rückseite anbringen
und das will ich direkt an der an der
wand kleben wir fangen gerade hier an
an diesem stoß oder alles schon gemacht
hat und arbeiten und deshalb von rechts
nach links
ganz einfach zeit und jetzt zeigen wie
es geht
[Musik]
das wichtig ist ihr auch ganz ganz
wichtig ist da anfangen wenn ihr am
anfang schon mist baut dann wird das
nachher immer schlimmer das heißt von
anfang an richtig alles in wasser haben
also alles gerade haben oder das gemacht
hat kann nichts mehr schief gehen und es
klebt schon richtig fest daran wahnsinn
cool der kleber ist echt zu bauen
[Musik]
übrigens diese wieder hier das nennt man
faulenzer und zwar ganz einfach so
stützt hilfen
die bretter an gepresst werden deshalb
mit faulenzer was mir übrigens auch
faulenzer nennt ist damit zeigen ist
dieser mensch hier
den hätte man auch faulenzer hat aber
nichts mehr essen stücks hinten zu tun
weil selbst die staatshilfen machen
etwas was er nicht machen juni habe ich
recht woran ich den finger nicht hat
so jetzt meint das letzte brett rein und
zwar habe ich jetzt ein bisschen
angeschrägt dass es besser rein geht
super passt wir haben jetzt die leitung
da haben wir auch gemacht jetzt haben
wir ja hier dieses brett was wir jetzt
noch machen ist einfach mit dem alex war
hier einfach ist hier so eine kante rein
sondern noch mal eine leitung darüber
dass man diese flächen nicht mehr sieht
sich daher ganz cool aus das problem ist
einfach nachher sein wenn ich hier auch
ein brettchen machen sollte dann habe
ich nachher probleme im fenster aufgeht
deswegen hier einfach nach einem holz
drüber richtig cool winkel und es passt
halt perfekt so hat gesehen wir haben
die wandvertäfelung gemacht man muss ein
bisschen improvisieren das passiert was
manchmal auf dem bau passiert ist sehr
sehr oft und das was ihr hier seht diese
nische hier direkt dass ich ihn drauf
setzen kann
vielleicht habt ihr mal lust hier zu
sitzen oder vielleicht mal auf ein
schlechtes buch zu lesen
ich habe ich übrigens gerade ein
schlechtes buch wo ich dann einfach mal
wenn mir langweilig ist was es nicht der
fall ist aber ich habe meinen schlechten
roman lesen möchte habe ich gerade
dieses buch hier das kann man sich vor
ort kann man sich in röcken und wissen
dass lesen
das hier ist aus der not entstanden und
zwar da wo ich jetzt gerade sitze war
eigentlich ein raum geplant und wir
haben das dann in der bauphase
umgeworfen
da wo ich jetzt gerade sitze war ich im
wc geplant und diese nische hier ist
entstanden weil hier drin laufen
wasserrohre und ich wollte das büro ein
bisschen größer haben
deswegen haben wir so einen kasten um
die wasserrohre gebaut und habe ich mir
einfach eine weltkugel können wir nicht
so eine coole sitznischen machen und man
was zu lesen aus dem fenster zu schauen
und das ist aus der not entstanden muss
ich sagen und allerdings immer her dass
hatte absichtlich gemacht absolut nicht
habe dann im plan umgeworfen pläne
umwerfen mit dem bau ist normalerweise
immer eine teure sache war es auch muss
ich ehrlich sagen dann haben wir im alex
zusammen diesen kassen gebaut und haben
diesen kasten mit leder überzogen und
wie ich das gemacht habe
das schaut euch jetzt an
jetzt bin ich beim barcoo in hockenheim
wunderbar chor ist ein kumpel von mir
der hat schon einiges für mich gemacht
und jetzt lasse ich gerade diese die
polsterung leder und auch die
seitenwände
ich hoffe er kann mir weiterhelfen und
vor allem ich brauch schnell ist immer
gespannt ob es hinkriegt kommen wir
gegen kurz rein kommunales ist die kiste
von baakuba listing an
kilmer reinschauen mal der hat sogar das
armaturenbrett bezogen
der ist richtig durchgeknallt ich liebe
diesen typen sowas lenkrad richtig
genial also ein promo da ist
aber hier ist und zwar jetzt immer
gerade beim barcoo in seiner produktion
wenn man jetzt kann ich gleich ich zeige
ein paar sachen kurz mal ganz kurz
das ist ein sitz männer wenn er nur noch
alt ist er macht die oldtimer und das
ist sah sich so einer
wenn er wirklich frisch bezogen ist
wirklich der wahnsinn er macht auch
möbel wo man noch machen komplett hier
wir die bezieht in allem drum und dran
halt die möbel restaurieren eine ganz
ganz geniale geschichte und jetzt gucken
wo ich mein brett hier marco christ und
christian bakkerud ich habe ein
riesenproblem und zwar folgendes erklärt
ich mache es ganz kurz
baku ich habe so das ist wie müll
beziehen so ähnlich ich habe dieses
brett ist hatte alex schon geschnitten
und das brett müssten wir mit leder
beziehen und zwar ist es nach etwas zum
hinsetzen
das ist eine fensterbank so richtig cool
und da bräuchte ich wirklich ganz ganz
schnell ich weiß du hast viel stress
übrigens hier
das ist ein porsche targa es richtig
genau machen die komplette ausstattung
auch innen und außen komplett wünschbare
weil ich bin die ablage ist es okay das
sind ganz erfreut sind alles neue bezüge
kommen dann der teppich rein und
besitzer und die tür also als
gemeinsamer torah bright wo macht es
irgendwann vielleicht ein freund von dir
oder im komponieren kundert ist die
kundschaft die kommen immer hier und
machen wir die arbeit
ok wack und du kennst mich kann es etwas
günstiges was ist das günstigste und das
ist kunst
das heißt also schlechter ist gut okay
das ist auch gutes material also das ist
kann man reden
für uns was aus okay ich habe jetzt gar
nicht die sagen welche farbe ich haben
möchte aber genau das ist die farbe
wirklich packen wir das wird genau von
der breite kommentiert ist ja
passt perfekt als ob ich schon mal da
gewesen wäre und das schon mal
abgemessen hätte perfekt baku war cool
marco könntest du mir die sitzfläche
könnte es können wir die vielleicht
gleich machen werde es möglich sein kann
man probieren können wir auch wie es
funktioniert hey super jetzt bleiben wir
jetzt beim craften barcoo da und schauen
uns an wie er das macht das wird noch
richtig cool jetzt okay
[Musik]
myspace haben wir kommen so tritt er der
hat bestimmt genug arbeit und nehmt mich
jetzt einfach dran und macht nur ein
brett kurz fertig war konnte wissen wie
ich der wahnsinn willst das ist man cool
das ist echt der wahnsinn der
gleichzeitigkeit das machen wir
natürlich hat auch gesehen einer branche
spezielle werkzeug ist die säge machst
du gerade hat die schere habe ich zum
ersten mal sowas gesehen dass es
überhaupt so was gibt der wahnsinn
und jetzt tust du das alles ist so ein
kleber ist ein kontakt lieber kontakt
und jetzt werde beide seite verlassen
dann wäre so fünf minuten und dann kann
man vertraut und das ist fixiert und es
ist ein ganz spezieller schaumstoff der
kommt aus england den gibt es in
deutschland nicht importiert ja immer
eine ganz coole geschichte wirklich in
so glücklich gerade wenn ich habe daheim
ist so viel stress gerade und jetzt dass
es jetzt ratz fatz funktioniert hat ist
ein ganz ganz selten erreichen
[Musik]
kunstlehrer ist natürlich etwas
günstiger als ein cooler stopp oder oder
baku ist stoff noch günstiger und da
gibt stolz teurer als das leben echt
wirklich
also ich hab jetzt natürlich aber er
wird sich das günstigste genommen oder
nein also unser material ist wirklich
hochwertige material kongress aus durch
joker händler keine ausländische
asiatische okay
[Musik]
also jetzt ist der match stehen mache
ich das denn wahr und dann sagst du ich
habe das geschafft sie haben also
letzten mal hin und hoffentlich passiert
nichts
dann geht auf kohlen morgen
heranzuarbeiten zähle ich kündige so
mache in baku nur noch immer hier
[Gelächter]
richtig cool
man ist jetzt meine fensterbank und baku
jetzt habe ich noch zwei tage bis man
kann es mir nicht fertigmachen bis
freitags ok alles da also komme ich am
freitag auf der rest abholt hauptsache
man die fensterbank und weiß wie es
aussieht und danke noch mal dass dort
knapp geklappt hat dankeschön gehören
gewissen schatz sagt also jetzt mit den
oster alex wartet schon
das brett geholt alex hat ja auch schon
weiter gemacht da alex haben alex haben
uns entschieden dass hier oben jetzt mit
holz lassen weil es einfach leichter mit
den ausstellern für richter und jetzt
alle mal gucken und mehr maßgenau
gearbeitet haben oder
[Musik]
ja perfekt
guck mal auf
jetzt sitzen eine ganze tag ne geile
geschichte der firma auf und zwar hier
haben wir noch ein loch aber da kommen
wir auf das andere brett rand der
zweimal die richtige handwerker und dass
man das kenntlich machen und wir gehen
einfach wieder das was wir immer machen
fernsehen und playstation
ich freu' ich mich so als will ich lesen
weil oftmals keine zeit dazu aaron ist
kein spaß das buch ist gut
hast du cool gemacht so habe ich zwar
auch ein cooles accessoire es einfach
lustig aus cool wäre es noch wenn ich
noch einmal runter hätten und einfach
die ganzen schnitzel reinwerfen könnte
ein basketballkorb liegt laut adam riese
laut den statuten der rwe ungefähr bei
272 ihr seht ich könnt ja locker einen
dunking machen
ich bin großer wahnsinns ding cooles
accessoire ein cooler blickfänger
irgendwie leute reinlaufen sagen so cool
dass basketballkorb und ich sage ja hast
du recht ist massaker so was ein abstieg
eccher auch im haus ist sind diese türen
und zwar ist diese tür metalltür 53 hoch
und da wirklich ziemlich klein ich will
gewinnen obwohl ich selber 195 bin ist
wirklich der wahnsinn und die idee bei
dieser tour war auch ganz einfach ich
hatte auch parkett übrig eine dunkle
variante auch von kers oder mich zum
holzstab nach bockenheim
ich möchte noch gerne erwähnen weil wir
immer unternehmen aus der region oder
aus der stadt raus da nee wieso ist ein
support möchten und und dann unsere
sachen aufholen und zwar der hat dann
das dem parkett genommen dem ich ihm
zugeschickt habe und er hat diese tür
dann mit diesem parkett verkleidet ist
eine richtig geniale geschichte macht
auch was es ist ein absolutes unikat
diese tür und sind hammermäßig außen
immer wenn leute zu besuch kommen sie
vor was ist denn das ist ja wahnsinn
und ich kenne es bleibt bei autos
gemacht beginnen beispiel im mercedes
und schlagt die tür zugeknallt gemacht
und dann könnt ihr vielleicht möchte
jetzt kein deutscher fahrer hätten dann
nimmst du vielleicht ein dacia schlägt
thürauf dann machst du noch klingen bei
dieser tür hört mal kurz hin nochmals
mikrofon konzern couleur
ich weiß zum beispiel wie zum beispiel
zur miete wohnt was ja auch jahrelang
gemacht haben oder nicht sein wenn es
nicht ein eigenes haus ist dann kann man
wirklich auch weniger wert auf diverse
dinge legen
aber da ich hoffe ja dass sich selina
scheiden lässt und dass wir edel in
diesem haus wohnt möchten etwas rein
machen wo wir sagen hey das bleibt für
immer drin und habe mich auf qualität
extrem viel wert gelegt und auch sogar
bei den türen und bei den türen merckx
immer wenn ihr die tür nimmst du grad zu
nehmen kannst und wegschmeißen kannst
dann ist es meist keine gute tür da gibt
es auch noch mal unterschiede zwischen
haben türen röhren sparen und eine
momentan voll holztüren türen sind auch
so wie soll ich sagen das ist auch
irgendwie es in den visitenkarte und wir
haben damit nicht auf qualität wert
gelegt und es ist absolut ding diese
zürich hat weiß auch schon gesagt hat
180 kilo also will ich da wahnsinn
ja danke markus jetzt habe ich mal die
wände die türen und die fenster und
alles gezeigt und jetzt kommt auch etwas
wo viele viele menschen nachfragen wenn
sie mal ab und zu bei den stories of
instagram oder so fotos mal sehen und
zwar es geht um den boden und zwar wir
haben natürlich haben wir über eine
fußbodenheizung drin
und jetzt kommt das ganz cool ist und
schau dir mal diesen boden an und zwar
ist dieser bodensicht beton estrich und
zwar hat uns den boden der mortimer auch
aus hockenheim gemacht hockenheim jetzt
von uns vielleicht zwei drei kilometer
entfernt macht nicht jeder
und jetzt vielleicht viele der ist
richtig teuer ist absolut nicht im
gegenteil ist ein absolutes schnäppchen
und zwar wenn ihr zum beispiel zu hause
auf dem bau einen fußboden macht dann
brauchte erstmal ein fußboden estrich er
legt diesen fußboden estrich der kost um
die kommt nur darauf an wo es machen
lasst zwischen 35 und 50 euro
und wer das gemacht habt kommt auf
diesen estrich noch mal zusätzlichen
fußbodenbelag wenn ihr in einem
hochwertigen packen
oder einen hochwertigen fußbodenbelag
nimmt mit der arbeit zusammen seid ihr
vielleicht nach haar bei 80 euro das
heißt 35 bis 50 euro der estrich plus 80
euro sei nachher bei 130 140 euro pro
quadratmeter
sie können gar nichts gar nichts wenn
ihr das wirklich was tolles mit
klassisches haben möchte und so ein
fußboden estrich kommt auch darauf an
dass ich mich jetzt nicht mit werken
festlegen weil sich das immer
unterscheidet weil so ein fußboden erst
recht zwischen 80 und 100 euro das heißt
er ist eigentlich relativ günstig und
für den fußboden estrich hat mich
entschieden weil er ist leicht sauber zu
machen
man sieht nicht die flecken drauf weil
er so eine zunahme um drin hat und er
ist pflegeleicht was ich aber das
nächste mal gemacht hätte da habe ich
einen kleinen fehler gemacht das würde
ich nicht mehr machen und zwar mit einem
tick heller machen also wenn er so ein
boot macht macht ihr nicht so dunkel
hier machte er noch mal einen tick
heller da sie noch weniger drauf und das
ist einiger dinge wo ich richtig stolz
darauf hin dass es gemacht habe wenn
neun uns besuchen kommen oder die
meisten fragen sind immer was ist im
boden ist sich beton estrich macht aber
wirklich nicht jeder ihr werdet in
deutschland vielleicht eine handvoll
finden die das überhaupt machen und ganz
ganz ehrlich er ist wirklich nicht teuer
aber erst mit raffiniert so jetzt habe
ich euch die wände die türen und alles
den boden alles erklärt und jetzt geht
es ums interieur
aber es geht auch ein bisschen smarthome
wenn er vielleicht das video mal sell it
smart home mal angeschaut habt wisst ihr
dass er den ganzen haus loks und smart
home system haben ist was richtig
geniale es ist keine gimmicks ist ein
real smartphone das heißt ich muss im
ganzen haus keine schalter betätigen
weil alles automatisch funktioniert
das heißt ich komme hier in das büro
rein das licht geht an wenn ich lust
hätte mein liebling spotify playlist com
es ist zum beispiel so du arbeitest hier
du hast wir einen laptop vielleicht hier
das licht scheint rein oder smartphone
erkennt die lichteinstrahlung und fährt
automatisch die gestattung runter ist
ein ganz geniale geschichte das heißt du
musst nichts mehr machen oder wenn ich
zum beispiel das team auch selber runter
fahren möchte kann am schalter machen
am von am luxus schalter oder ich habe
hier diesen look sohn würfeln der ist
auf meinem schreibtisch der ist auf
einmal ist becker uhr
und es ist auch ein lichtschalter das
heißt ich habe gerade möchte vielleicht
musik spielen lassen oder ich lasse die
rolle jetzt per hand runter fahren da
kann ich einmal hier links runden drauf
drücken und schon fährt runter oder ich
halts kurz an sagt unfalls oder hoch
oder ich kann es auch schlicht ausmachen
kurz natürlich einfach hier
zack zack zack das licht ist aus richtig
geniale geschichte wie gesagt komplett
ausgespart mit lok schon das ganze haus
auch dieses arbeitszimmer nimmt einem
viel viel arbeit ab ist wirklich nicht
irgendeine spielerei sondern etwas
sinnvolles also schaut euch mal dieses
video an
sally smartphone es ist richtig genial
so jetzt habt ihr ein bisschen
smartphone gesehen
jetzt geht es weiter und zwar was könnte
jedes büro rein natürlich das mobiliar
das komplette mobiliar und karlsruhe
holt beim xxx lutz wie eigentlich fast
alle unsere möbel und beim xxx lutz da
könnt ihr auch möbel aussuchen ein
kleines budget für ein mittleres budget
für wenn ihr etwas luxuriöses wollten
das luxuriöse holen das heißt da gibt es
für jeden geldbeutel irgendwas und auch
für jeden anspruch und da es unser
eigenes haus ist sind wir so in der
mittleren schiene gewesen dh nicht zu
teuer nicht zu günstig qualität und bei
uns war halt auch ganz wichtig beachten
zu ein lebensmüder auf regionalität und
da dachten wir uns warum nicht meine
möbel darunter schrank geholt bei xxx
lutz und das ist bei uns der nähe und
ansonsten noch mal wirklich auf coole
möbel aus der region geachtet
das ist uns extrem wichtig für den
anderen ist der preis vielleicht
wichtiger wenn er vielleicht in der
mietwohnung lebt da kann auch was
anderes holen dort und für eine
vielleicht luxus haben ist gibt es auch
leute so nix sagen waren in der
mittleren kategorie und da haben wir uns
für münster entschieden
und zwar beim lutz gab es zum beispiel
höchster münster hatten ganz cool slogan
and richtig cool finde uns war die
stelle in deutschland her und die sagen
tropenhölzer gehören und die tropen wir
nehmen nur heimische hölzer und deswegen
haben wir uns gerade bei den schränken
beim schreibtisch ist alles von hülsta
mannschaft es natürlich nicht immer bei
möbel auf regionalität zu achten also so
so so fair muss man auch sagen jetzt
schafft man wirklich nicht manchmal ist
es die seien von dem möglich ist so
genial
dann schauen wir mal drüber aber wenn es
möglich ist dann macht es auch das sind
arbeitsplätze in der region hier in
deutschland oder auch in österreich und
haben ein cooles dieter stolte zum
beispiel aus österreich wir haben auch
etwas weniger aber trotzdem was ganz
ganz cooles von team 7
und wie gesagt tropenholz so gar nicht
open mit dem nur heimische hölzer und
das ist wirklich komplett aus der
höchster serie für die eine coole sache
ist auch langlebig wir sind auch keine
menschen die zum beispiel alle drei vier
jahre komplettieren möbel stil ändern
deutschland ist sich dass das land wo
die meisten leute am meisten müll
gekauft um schiedsrichter bahn sind
deutschland ist ein richtiges möbel land
aber wir sind natürlich irgendwie
unserem einen schwäbischen gene sagen
hey du kaufst jetzt was und es hält ewig
und das soll auch stylisch sein und auch
langlebig und vom stil her soll es doch
zeitlos sein ich fand das richtig gut
von höchster haben uns die siege holten
richtig coole qualität die jungs von xxx
lutz zusammen aufgebaut
beim aufbauen von möbel habe ich immer
angst ich mache viel kaputt deswegen
haben die einen aufbau service komplett
genutzt war richtig genial
der schreibtisch ist auch von lutz und
von höchster und den kannst du beliebig
erweitern das heißt es ist ein modulares
system
du kannst ja sachen dazu holen
irgendwann mal wenn das irgendwie
größeres büro kann ich vielleicht am
zweiten tisch reinholen da kommt dennis
unser baby kommt da rein
hier sind diese stange hier da hängen
normalerweise hänge pflanzen aber die
pflanzen haben irgendwie läuse
willkommen deswegen hat sie die mama
weggenommen
ansonsten auch das ganze in früher war
es hier drin sind bilder von meiner
familie ich habe hier zwar schon kleines
bild von mir das ist mein bild es gibt
aus meiner kindheit nur ein einziges
bild und es
das hier und es ist das älteste bild was
ich habe ansonsten haben wir natürlich
auch ein paar coole sachen an den wänden
zum beispiel das ist ein bild seiner
damals von youtube bekommt das sind voll
mit kommentaren ein richtig cooles
sullivan ansonsten hängen hier bilder
von meinen kindern überall oder auch
hier waren wir zusammen beim creator
samen in paris aber auch von youtube
bekommen dann natürlich hier von der
samira das heißt im kindergarten gemacht
ich glaube jeder papa hat von seinen
kindern und bilder in seinem büro und
wenn nicht habt ihr das falsch gemacht
und deshalb samira für uns gemacht
richtig wunderschön
die kinder freuen sich auch über die
sachen aufhängen und ansonsten natürlich
viele viele bücher ich lese sehr viel
clips ich liebe es zu lesen
wobei das teilweise kochbücher sind von
freunden von uns die sich gleich
geschrieben haben dann natürlich
zeitschriften sachen von der rally zum
beispiel drin
ja und so sind die möbel hier drin aus
zum teil was auch mir ganz ganz wichtig
ist ist dass hier das wissen die türken
wissen ist unter euch während türkischem
migrationshintergrund heißt es in
türkischen büros ist oftmals so dass der
präsident an der wand hängt oder atatürk
einer der gründer der republik der
türkei oder oftmals hängen andere
politiker auch in deutschen büros und
ich hab immer gedacht politiker man mag
sie oder man mag sie nichts man muss man
von zwei beiden seiten betrachten dann
wird es immer nur stress geben und ich
hab mir gedacht hey was passt menschen
über die jeder lacht die ihr toll findet
und ich bin absoluter heinz erhardt fan
ich bin absolut heinz erfand fan ich
liebe heinz erhardt gibt man bei youtube
vielleicht heinz erhardt an wendy hill
vom heinz hermann schaus das sind so
genial wirklich daher auch beim lutz
rahmen geholt haben wir im internet ein
bild ausgedruckt ich weiß gar nicht ob
es legal ist ich habe es trotzdem
gemacht und habe mein herz hängt es ist
ein abschluss idiot von mir
es gibt wahrscheinlich keinen menschen
auf der welt der heinz erhardt nicht
liebt wie die wohl nicht kennen bitte
schaut euch diese filme an
genial auf der anderen seite
das ist meine herkunft einmal die
deutsche herkunft ich bin hier geboren
hier aufgewachsen ich liebe deutschland
und das sind meine wurzeln ich liebe
auch die türkei und die türkei hat auch
einen heinz erhardt nur heißt er kemmer
sommer und kämmerer so nah ist auch so
ein typ ich liebe kemmer sohn als filme
wie ich als kind damit aufgewachsen
kennt sondern ist ein wahnsinnig
genialer komiker und ich bin mir sicher
in der türkei gibt es keinen wirklich
niemanden der diesen typen nicht mag und
das war immer so ne wie soll ich sagen
das waren menschen die kein witze
gemacht haben über um über andere
menschen sondern über sich selber die
haben waren ab und sozialkritisch aber
die haben den leuten immer ein lachen
auf den lippen gezaubert und diese zwei
menschen repräsentieren nicht ich
versuche auch menschen zum lachen zu
bringen und diese menschen sind einfach
wundervoll und sind teil von mir also
rechts ein pferd linkscanner sommer von
der optik her wollte ich keine griffe
haben weil dann irgendwie immer dran
kommst aber komplett griff losgemacht
finde ich cool und das ist die push to
open funktion das heißt einfach
bush open was habe ich da drin und zwar
habe ich hier im poker koffer drin
ich habe mein leben noch nie poker
gespielt ich weiß auch gar nicht woher
das geht es glauben geschenkt wohl auch
nicht geöffnet hat noch nie poker
gespielt
ich kann nicht mal karten spielen muss
ich ehrlich sagen ja und wie gesagt auch
hier perfekt oder das hat meine frau
übrigens voll auch eingeräumt ja gesagt
du kannst die schränke nicht zeigen
mittendrin nach chaos herrscht aber wie
gesagt beim normalen menschen auch bei
uns an einem tag wo ich vielleicht
industrie ist jetzt nicht so aus
sicherlich sagen oder oder
ich sehe keine übermenschen so wenn man
das kind muss in rom eine schublade die
nicht ordentlich aussieht ist meine
schublade klebestifte reißnägeln allem
drum und dran
genial und die reist gleich auch ganz
ganz cool wenn ich die holzwand habe
kann ich auf der hölzernen auch die
reißleine und sachen dran und es sieht
man nachher nicht mehr richtig coole
geschichte perfekt
dieses sofa dürft euch auch aufgefallen
sein und zwar ist es auch vom xxx lutz
und diesmal haben wir auch der montage
lieferservice von xxx lutz in anspruch
genommen und dieses sofa ist von der
firma nähr und die firma nähe ist auch
made in germany und die machen ganz
besondere sachen jemand funktional
funktions möbel und es ist so ein
bisschen in waghäusel und es ist
wirklich in waghäusel wir haben nicht
viele hotels werden gleich zwei hotels
in waghäusel und dann ist rhi in der
region sehr stark ist sind die
hotelzimmer ausgebucht und zu uns kommen
auch mal oft freunde von weiter weg sein
schwestermodell aachen oder mal ein
geschäftspartner oder ein kumpeln freund
kommt uns besuchen und es ist für uns
eigentlich immer
ich bin es blöd wenn freunde zu besuch
kommen über das wochenende und ich würde
seinem hotel einfach ziehen wenn freunde
mich besuchen können dann möchte dass
sie bei uns kennt und deswegen haben wir
gedacht okay wir haben nicht so arg viel
räume also privaträume wir haben uns
gedacht wie kann man einen raum auch
umfunktionieren und daher uns von mehl
so ein bett geholt so klappt wie zeigen
was es eine ganz geniale geschichte was
gleich passiert jetzt schaut euch mal
das ding hier an
ihr seht es aus glas was jetzt passieren
para
[Musik]
ist es ist cool jetzt jetzt habe ich mir
einen raum gespart das heißt es ist auch
immer ein gästezimmer sozusagen das
heißt wenn jemand herkommt nicht
besuchen und seine familie besuchen
freunde haben wir auch gleichzeitig ein
gästebett und jetzt wenn jemand
vielleicht zum beispiel nicht so große
räume hat und viele viele zimmer hat
dann ist es eine ideale variante aus
einem büro zwei sachen zu machen
jetzt haben sie auch freunde gehabt wie
gesagt haben herr jetzt schlafen
irgendwelche fremden menschen oder
fremde menschen schlafen nicht bei uns
meistens freunde schlafen irgendwie
leute bei euch und jetzt hast du deine
ganzen büro daten seine ganzen zettel
und allem drum und dran
hier ist sichtlich unangenehm wenn über
eure zettel herum liegen aber dieses
büro ist will ich meine ganze
buchhaltung ist nicht hier ist beim
baden drüben und beim dennis und das ist
jetzt einfach im bett
und wie gesagt eine coole geschichte
jetzt haben wir aus einem raum auf aus
einem raum zwei räume gemacht jetzt
können die leute hier übernachten gar
kein problem
und das ist eine richtig coole massive
sache hier als kann man die schnallen
einfach wegmachen
zum beispiel kann darin schlafen und
allem drum und dran und das bett in das
neue bezogen ist einfach wieder zu
machen und du brauchst auch gar nicht
viel kraft jetzt passt man auch mit
einer hand
okay ich bin auch extrem starken muss
ich sagen und seht ihr das ding
das heißt wenn ich hier sogar blumen
stehen hätte wenn ich blumen stehen
hätte werden die blumen ist immer noch
oben geblieben also eine richtig coole
geschichte jetzt im einfach die kissen
wieder so
so schels traum und jetzt kein spaß das
ist made in germany
das ist nicht billig dass es preiswert
billig ist einfach billig preiswert ist
sein preis wert das wurde hier
hergestellt faire löhne bezahlt die
leute bekommen weihnachtsgeld
urlaubsgeld bisschen facharbeiter und
wenn man selber den anspruch hat um zu
arbeiten man möchte er verdienen dann
sollten es auch anderen menschen können
und wenn man die möglichkeit hat so als
kaufst du nicht alle drei vier jahren
sowas kaufst du einmal im leben finde
ich dass nico die geschichte so das ist
meine tochter spielt klavier
niemand in der familie mascali gespielt
aber dies ist die spitze nicht schnell
ich glaube dass ich meine tochter einen
moment märkte doch wahr sein von meiner
tochter und das war schon ein bisschen
ich hoffe ich konnte wissen was
mitnehmen
achtet auf qualität wenn ihr die
möglichkeit gehabt wirklich ende die
möglichkeiten achtet auf regionalität
auch beim möbelkauf die möglichkeiten
hat er auf jeden fall bei xxx lutz
ob das in karlsruhe ist es in mannheim
ist ein ziel hat auch in eurer nähe und
ist eine coole geschichte wenn ihr auch
darauf wert legt aber vielleicht seid
ihr auch die leute die sagen ich möchte
nach alle fünf jahren komplett mein
style wechseln wenn sich auch als
menschen ändern möchte finde auch ich
bin noch günstigen möbel dort wenn ihr
auf ganz ganz hochwertige marken
merklich findet natürlich auch eure
möbel das heißt für jeden was dabei
ihr habt gesehen manchmal kommt es
anders als man denkt man muss auch ein
bisschen improvisieren können ich habe
auch wirklich improvisiert habe auch ein
paar aufheller gehabt habe sie aber um
wieder ausmerzen können
ich hoffe haben was mitgenommen ein paar
inspiration und es wieder euch gefallen
an daumen nach oben wird mich wirklich
freuen war toll und wir sind wieder
zurück
[Musik]
schließt gratisbuch roland trettl
nachschlag das muster lesen das ist echt
witzig ja also das hier ist echt mein
lieblingsplatz in diesem zimmer wenn
nicht sogar nach der küche im ganzen
haus denn diese sitzen ich studiere ich
mir echt gewünscht gottseidank katzen
ein planungsfehler und während dieses
nische gemacht perfekt wahrscheinlich
als murat euch als direkte planung
verkauft aber nein es war ein
planungsfehler rohre und dann kam die
sitze aber die habe ich mir sowieso
gewünscht
ich finde den raum richtig schön also
vor allem habe ich mir echt ein büro
gewünscht wo ich daran arbeiten kann wo
ich aber auch dann entspannen kann und
mooren und grüne unter alex die haben
das echt super gemacht vor allem mit der
funktion dass es eben im büro ist aber
auch schlafmöglichkeiten bietet eben für
unsere gäste oder für murat wenn da mal
nicht so ganz freundlich zu mir war
nein das warten jetzt da schläft nicht
da schläft immer bei mir und ich werde
jetzt noch was ich machen werde wir
haben zwar das büro eingerichtet ich
habe auch schon meine bücher sortiert
nach kategorie was ich noch machen werde
ist dass sich das büro so ein bisschen
auf räume also ein bisschen system
reinbringen hat der berater die
schubladen gezeigt bestimmt sind noch
nicht so ganz aufgeräumt
das heißt ich werde noch so ein bisschen
organisieren wenn ihr möchtet dann mache
ich gerne ein büro organisiert hacks
video vielleicht habt ihr ja auch ideen
wie man die strecke noch schön
einrichten kann oder was man allgemein
noch machen kann
aber ich finde die drei haben das super
gemacht gefällt mir sehr gut vor allem
das schlafsofa also schlafsofa bett weil
man eben auf dem sofa tagsüber einfach
sitzen kann und es fällt wirklich keinem
auf das ist ein bett ist also richtig
genial
ja hat er echt super gemacht hat ihr
seht erschafft auch dinge ganz alleine
und hat dieses zimmer wirklich komplett
alleine geplant
vielen dank der baum hat ich lese
zweiter und bin auch ganz froh dass der
murat dieses video ganz alleine gemacht
hat und wenn ihr möchtet das buch hat
gerne öfter mal was alleine macht
beschreibt auch gerne in die kommentare
ich lese zweiter und wir sehen uns
wieder das nächste mal und wenn ihr die
hacks noch von mir sehen wollt dann
schreibt gerne in die kommentare
[Musik]
er ist dann kommt rein
schützen sie sich wir müssen reden ja
also ich hab jetzt festgestellt nach
jahren und auch die kollegen dass sie
gar nichts da war gar nix ja aber ich
war ich war immer der meinung dass das
immer alles gegeben habe wir haben
meinung interessiert mich nicht
er ist schon brot kann schwimmen ist man
damit machen warum böse will mich fertig
ihre meinung interessiert mich nicht
es ist schon brot kann schimmel nicht so
ganz kann schliesslich den menschen ja
gibt den menschen macht und du merkst du
siehst den wahren charakter
du wirst ein richtig eklige typ bist du
wenn du was zu sagen ist
wir sind brot gemüse das kann man auch
wieder wiederholen nicht verlieren
er macht das risiko gemacht dass er nach
bisher ist was ihre meinung interessiert
uns nicht
[Gelächter]
das tut man noch einmal nicht trennen